who is kiri's Father do all navies speak
the same language these Avatar 2 details
left a lot of fans drowning
Avatar the way of water starts with a
look at the 13 years of peace that Jake
natiri and the rest of the omotakaya
clan got to experience after the end of
the first movie The Tribe works on
repairing some of the destruction the
RDA cause during its tenure on Pandora
while Jake and natiri start a family and
end up raising four children after just
a few minutes of run time however that
piece is disrupted when humans via the
RDA return to the Moon to some it looks
like the massive space-faring vessels
that people use to travel the Stars land
on Pandora destroying huge swirls of the
ecosystem in the process what actually
happens is much darker The Starships at
Humanity uses to get to Pandora can't
actually land on the surface of the
planet humans need to use smaller
shuttles to get to the ground but when
they return to Pandora they momentarily
dip their larger ships into the moon's
Atmosphere by doing that they're able to
use their engines to burn away the
forest and establish a new mining colony
directly over a large deposit of of an
obtainium yeah can we just take this
down a couple of notches
spider whose real name is miles is one
of the most influential new characters
in Avatar the way of water he's just a
baby when the omotakaya forced the
humans to leave Pandora but there's no
safe way for a baby to be put in cryo
sleep the baby stays behind with a few
human scientists who remain on the moon
and he grows up with a foot in Two
Worlds money May physically be a human
spider loves the culture of the navi and
he spends a majority of his time with
the Sully children it doesn't take long
for the film to reveal that spider's
father was actually quarriage from the
first avatar however the film never
explains who spider's mother is fans
might walk out of the theater thinking
that spider's mother left Pandora with
the other humans abandoning her son on
the moon but that isn't the case at all
spiders first introduction to the Avatar
Universe came in the comic The High
Ground where it was revealed that his
mother was a pilot working on Pandora
who died during the fight with the Oma
Takaya it turns out that both of his
parents were working to kill the people
who would end up raising their son
one of the biggest surprises in avatar
The Way of water is Stephen Lang's
return as Courage the aggressively
militaristic leader of the RDA incumbent
in the first movie he happily destroyed
home tree and dreamed of crushing the
omotakaya completely then he and Jake's
Sully squared off and thaturi ended his
life with a well-timed arrow in the way
of water not only is courage back but
he's also blue so how did this happen at
some point during the events of the
original Avatar the RDA made a scan of
courage's brain his experience on
Pandora was so valuable that the RDA
wanted to preserve it for a worst case
scenario that resulted in Croatia's
death when the omitakaya booted the
humans off Pandora the scan got sent
back to Earth there the RDA inserted
courage's memories and personalities
into a vac-grown navi body so they could
send him back to the Moon with a whole
new range of abilities and available to
humans quarre rich in the way of water
is basically a clone of his former self
but there's no telling what effect is
new physiology will ultimately have on
his personality and views on Pandora
in the movie the team of Navi avatars
led by Colonel Miles courage capture
spider when Jake realizes that his old
enemy has returned and that's someone
who knows all their secrets has been
compromised he convinces nades here that
they need to leave the Oma Takaya to
protect their family and their tribe
obviously getting as far away from
Courage and the RDA as possible will
help keep the Sully family safe but it's
not exactly clear why Jake thinks
leaving will help the Oma Takaya for the
time being the sullies are the rda's top
priority but one way or another or the
navi and Pandora are going to have to
fight against a human invasion of course
by the end of the film Jake comes around
to the idea that there's nowhere to run
and decides that he and his family will
once again join the fight let's get it
done the way of water makes some
significant changes to the rda's
original Mission of stealing an
obtainium an immensely powerful energy
source worth of Fortune when humans
return to Pandora they use their ship
engines to burn massive sections of
forests to the ground with plants and
animals out of the way setting up a
mining Depot that can dig up as much
unobtainium as possible becomes a
trivial matter now the humans have two
new primary objectives on Pandora First
is the hunting of underwater creatures
called Tolkien though the Tolkien are
every bit as intelligence and empathetic
as human beings their brains produce an
oil that's capable of stopping human
aging so the RDA begins hunting them
into Extinction the bigger Mission
however is preparing Pandora to be the
new home for Humanity
when Jake and his family leave the Oma
Takaya they've played the forest in
search of a new home the Mets kaina live
along the edge of the ocean and they
spend a majority of their time
underwater swimming along the reef
communicating with creatures like the
Tolkien and Gathering resources to
survive with green skin and fin like
appendages the mechauna looked
distinctly different from the Oma Takaya
and they have cultural practices that
help them to adapt to life in the water
Just Breathe breathe despite all the
differences between the two tribes when
the sullies arrive at the metcalina's
home they have no trouble communicating
with their would-be protectors how can
two tribes from different parts of the
world with wildly different cultures
speak the same language it might be easy
to consider the shared language a
typical Movie cheat moment but there's
actually something more complex going on
here all life on Pandora is linked
spiritually and physically through AWA
by connecting themselves to Sacred
objects at the Spirit tree the navi can
commune with all of Nature and even with
their ancestors it's thanks to This
Global Network that all the navi are
able to communicate with each other
freely
a token hold a special place in
metcalina society individual Med coyina
form a kind of Soul Bond with a Tolkien
that makes a Tolkien part of the family
from the tribe's perspective while the
tolkiens spend much of their time in the
open ocean every year they return to the
Meg kaina to reconnect with their Navi
siblings and share stories of everything
that's happened in their time apart from
each other the met kawino and the
Tolkien don't speak the same language
but they do manage to communicate with
each other effectively for the most part
the Meg kaina taught to their soul
siblings with a kind of sign language
that lets them form words while staying
underwater a Tolkien speak with their
own language and communicate as much as
they can through their actions the fact
that they met Karina and the Tolkien
understand each other probably has a
little to do with their connection
through AWA it also speaks to the
incredible intelligence of the Tolkien
and a length of time the two groups have
been connected to each other
Jerry is one of the most mysterious
characters in Avatar the way of water
near the end of the original Avatar Jake
and the omatakaya attempt to save the
life of Doug De Grace Augustine by
permanently transferring her
Consciousness into her Avatar
unfortunately Grace doesn't survive the
process but her Avatar remains
physically alive and gives birth to Kiri
sometime after the film ends Jake and
naitiri adopt Kiri into their family in
the 13 years between the two films no
one steps forward as curie's father Kiri
obviously loves being a member of the
Sully family but she still wonders who
her real father could be while communing
with the spirit tree Kiri gets the
opportunity to speak with Grace's
Consciousness she asks about her father
but before Grace can answer Kiri begins
having a seizure severing her connection
to the spirit tree the story behind
Kerry's conception left more than one
fan confused but it's clearly a mystery
that's being set up for a future movie
to explore
when Kiri has a seizure during her visit
to the spirit tree she nearly drowns
after that she's unconscious and in
critical condition so Norman Max survive
at the Meg hyena Village via helicopter
to treat Kiri ultimately it's ronal's
healing practices that save Kyrie for
some unknown reason but Norm tells Jake
about kiri's seizure and warns him not
to let his adopted daughter return to
the spirit tree considering that the
Sully's traveled all the way to the
meccauna Village to separate themselves
from the resistance fight happening back
in the forest it seems strange that Jake
has a way to communicate with his human
friends the movie doesn't show how he's
able to reach out to Norman Max but it's
possible that his regular wearable calm
survives for the range that reaches all
the way back home the helicopter flight
to the Village ends up clueing quarries
and his team into the Sully's location
so hopefully Jake learns to operate a
little more under the radar in the
future
throughout the movie Kiri demonstrates a
connection to AWA that goes beyond what
the other Navi experience Kiri tells
Jake that she can feel awar around her
more than once Curie shows off that
she's able to somehow influence her
natural life around her whether through
some kind of telepathic communication or
outright mind control what's especially
interesting is that Kiri doesn't always
influence the plants and animals around
her in the same way when she lies down
in the forest the grass pulses and
ripples outward from her body later in
the medcarina village Kiri moves her
hands and the schools of fish mimics her
but the movie's climax Curie needs to
physically connect to a group of plants
before using them to ensnare the people
chasing her one way or another kiri's
intense connection to AWA allows her to
influence the living things in her
environment the exact rules of her
influences are going to have to be
sustowed by another Avatar movie The
Wealth of this world isn't in the ground
it's all around us
spider spends most of the way of water
with courage who just who happens to be
the navi clone of spiders real father
growing up spider knew that his dad was
a man who destroyed home tree and killed
countless Navi so when he meets corrich
he has no real interest in spending time
with him quarreish on the other hand
seems almost immediately pulled towards
spider crawrich makes spider act as his
Navi interpreter and all-around guide to
Pandora as a trade-off courage wouldn't
let the RDA torture spider for
information about the sullies it might
be understandable if spider becomes
attached to his pseudo father during
their time together but over and over
again spider challenges Crouch's actions
and tries to get him to stop destroying
lives at the end of the film crorage
Leicester Sully children get away in
order to save spider's life not long
after that spider sees quarrywich
drowning and pulls him onto land spider
might have saved quarreich as a way of
returning the favor or just because he
let the Tolkien is committed to the idea
of not killing but either way his choice
is sure to have repercussions on the
future of the Avatar story
[Music]